Hey guys, we're about to do an episode of Smart List, are you guys ready? Are you ready? Coming in hot. My brain thinks too fast before my mouth. Are you just sliding us in here? Yeah. I'm sliding us in here because I just, I like the energy, I like the energy in my voice right now.
I like how fast I'm talking. I'm really excited for the episode. You guys on board to listen or what? Sean, sit down. Sorry. Just take a second. Sit back down. Here comes some smartness.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. I don't want you to take this the wrong way, but can I ask you a question? Is that the part I'm going to take the wrong way or is it the question that's coming? Here's the question. In the last 12 hours, have you been chugging soy sauce? Boy, that's a pretty shiny glass house. You just clean those windows?
You fucking. But there's a lot of sodium in those hot dogs at the diner stadium. And especially the veggie dogs, which you know, my soft Hollywood ass eats. And then the. Of course you do. You cut the dog into a salad form. By the way, we've all seen your hot, hot saggy ass in Ozark. It's a nice ass.
Yeah. It's, it's not funny. And then I had four bags of peanuts. Those come salted. But you know what? I'm. Did you really have four bags of peanuts? Yeah.
But they're smaller this year. So it's really two. Oh, okay. That's what you tell yourself. That's a good story. You tell yourself. I love. I love.
I love a. Bag of nuts. I was going to do a nut joke and. Bag of nuts. You say it. You love chugging nuts. Yeah. You know, in my mouth and a bad nice bag of nuts.
Yeah. But it's cheap. This is a cheap joke. It is cheap. Yeah. You know, you know what I was going to. You know what was driving me crazy? I was thinking about, uh, you drive into the thing was like driving.
We had never talked about driving on the show. I had a guy yesterday park his car half in a parking spot. And so that his right bumper was almost an inch from my door. So I couldn't get back into my car. And I was like, Hey man, and I, and I see this woman. I go, look at this parking job. And this woman's on the other side of me going to get in her car and she goes, Oh, I thought you were talking about mine because my parking is not great because she had in fairness.
She did tend to the parallel parking with no other cars around her and bail because it wasn't great. But I love watching somebody bail from a parking with all that extra space. She actually looked over at me when he was, and I was sitting there with the kids were waiting for food sitting outside this restaurant and she looks at me and I kind of went, but just kind of like that. Non-judgment, like as much as I could, right? So anyway, so then I go to look, find the guy and he's picking up like five pizzas and
I go, Hey man, is this your car? You've parked in front of my door. So again, he goes one second and I go, No, no, no, no, you're waiting for, he goes there. Just one second. The other, the other people parked there. I'm, no, I'm just picking up my phone one second and I'm like, Oh, am I on your time now? Did you say that?
So I wait for this guy. You didn't say it. I didn't say that. That's something I would do, but you think it. I say it and it's, it's a problem though. And I'm the pizza guy. So he, and you're the pizza guy. So as he comes back and I'm like, I'm believe, I go, this guy is so inconsiderate and this
woman goes, she goes, I love smartness. I listen to smartness every day and I go, well, this is going to make it into the show. So you're going to hear. So you're out there, whoever you are. She's a very nice lady. So the guy comes back with the pizzas and it comes back and he finally, and he's like, these other people parked on the other side of me and he was like Italian or something because you kept them in there and parked on the other side and I couldn't get it in
anyway. And I'm like, Oh, okay. Yeah. So anyway, so you're good. Are you good now? Are you all loaded up? Can I load my car now? Yeah.
With myself. You know what it is? You know what it is? It's when people do shit and they have zero consideration for the world around them, which is a lot. It's like people with their driving again. It's like blinkers. Yeah.
It's like, put your fucking blinker on man. I know. That just happened to me yesterday. Our guest, I bet you he wishes people would use their blinkers because this would impact him directly because of what he does because he rides motorcycles. Well, let's just say this. He's a real life action hero and that his job and Arnold Schwarzenegger and I said real life.
Oh, I said, wait, oh, wait, I can, I can pick it off the laugh right. This is a guy who turned pro and what he does at the age of 14, I'm pretty sure. He dominated for about a dozen years of being the number one at what he does. He's the first person ever in competition to pull off a 900. What they call a nine at the 1999 X games. He is one of the most recognizable people in the world. He is. He's got all sorts of foundations.
He's now got a new podcast that is going out to the whole world. He's an incredible. Tony Hawk talks about shit. His name is Anthony Hawk. Tony Hawk. Tony Hawk. Come on. There it is.
What's up? Hello there. Tony, welcome to the podcast, man. Yeah, nice to meet you. So excited to have you here, man. I've just, I'm so. Thank you. Such a huge fan of what you do.
I'm available. You're one of those people. I watch what you do when I go every single time. I could never do that. I could never do that. Nothing you do could I do. Is that the name of your new podcast? Tony Hawk talks about shit.
No, that's not the name of your new podcast. What is the name of your new podcast? It is called Hawk versus Wolf and it is with my friend, Jason Ellis, who had a very good run of success on SiriusXM and he and I started actually on SiriusXM together about 15 years ago and both left there eventually and decided to come back together and tell our stories. It's fun. He is hilarious and has been in some of the craziest situations and I have my share of stories too.
Wow. First of all, what Sean is chomping at the bit. He loves people's crazy scenario situation stories more than probably anything and he's hoping that involves you being hurt, but let me just ask you this Tony and you've been asked this a million times and I'm sure you're bored, but take us back. You started as a pro skater when you were a teenager. What was that? What was that moment of like you're a kid who skates, you know, grew up in Southern California
and all of a sudden what you're doing it professionally. What was that? You're kind of in quotes, right? Because there wasn't a bunch of money in that business at the time, right? Right. Yeah. It's more along those lines. It was kind of like being deemed a professional hula hooper.
There were no contracts being offered to me. I basically entered a, I filled out an entry form to a competition and instead of checking amateur I checked professional and that was it. I was pro. I moved up a class in competition and I was competing for $100 first place prize, but I was 14 and a hundred bucks, you know, I was on my way to buying a moped. So it felt awesome because it was, you know, in terms of like where I, what I was doing in the world I was in, that was the, that was the top of the line.
But I never imagined it'd be a career. Not at all. And so you made me turning pro wasn't a huge deal in terms of the purses and stuff initially, but you are like going to competitions with that just Southern California where you instantly kind of around the country, around the world. At that moment in skating, it was almost exclusively in Southern California. Okay. Yeah.
The doggedown ZYZ area had kind of ended and skating was starting to sort of implode. And so the only skate parks around were in Southern California. And so I was, my dad was driving me to all of them. So was there a sort of, was there a moment in that industry where stuff blew up? And I'll bet you were either a part of that or solely responsible for that or certainly in attendance at whatever event that was where, where things went, oh my God, this is now, you could definitely sense it was the start of sort of the X games or what helped out with snowboarding and did a bunch of things coalesce at a certain moment and the industry
became white hot. Yeah. I think that's the perfect storm was the X games was on the rise in popularity in the late nineties. Our first video game was released in 1999 and all of those things happened at the right time and skating blew up in the early 2000s and got to a point where I never imagined. I never dreamed that we would be on television or be doing arena tours and it was wild. And it kind of, I mean, it has wavered a bit in popularity, but the foundation is set and
I feel like it's always going to sort of be there as a choice for kids to be doing it as readily as baseball or basketball. How much time do you spend thinking about pushing the sport forward in developing not only just new tricks because I mean, I think gravity will probably present the ceiling against that, but thinking about incorporating, you know, those frigging little those scooters like blades or those motorized skateboards or like, are you do you feel a burden to think about? Okay, what's next?
And I've got to stamp this. I've got to drive it. I've got to keep the sport growing so it doesn't plateau out that do you feel a responsibility for that at all? I guess I do in a sense, but I don't, I think of it just more along the lines of fun and how do we continue to keep the awareness of skating or to broaden the reach of skating. But I can tell you, the Olympics are going to do that by default. Next month, skateboarding is making its debut in Tokyo 2021 Olympics.
That's so exciting. That's amazing. I would assume you're going to be there. Are you going to be a part of that in some capacity? I am going to be there. NBC has me doing interviews and wrap ups and things, but they haven't actually given me my exact job description yet. So I'm just excited to be invited because it's not easy to get to Tokyo to even be there
at all. Yeah. Maybe your job description is just go over there and be rad and be Tony Hawk. By the way, speaking of rad, it's a word I still use and I don't, I imagine you use it too. There's a lot of flak for using it. It's still okay to use rad, right? I feel like it's come full circle.
Like it wasn't cool and now let's, we're back in it. We're so back in it. You know what? Tony Hawk and I are back in it with the rad. Hang on, Jason. I'm still basking in the glow of- He has validated that. How do you feel? I feel like the clothing version of that is overalls.
I would like to offer that as maybe something. I really miss wearing overalls. I wore that a lot back when rad was invented and which is short for radical, Tracy. And I would like overalls back in. So if you could maybe put that into the culture, I'd appreciate that. I don't know if I have that much pull. We can bring back rad. We can make it cool.
Overalls would be hard. Wait, Tony, what are you doing in New York? I'm here for our anniversary. My wife and I, we actually escaped the kids for the weekends. Yeah. You know what? By the way, Tony, you don't have to answer that. He's kind of grilling about his personal life, what he's doing with his wife.
He's having a nice weekend alone. He wants to know what shows you're going to go see and I'll bet you're a big musical fan, right? Yeah. Are you? Do you have any great Broadway stories, Tony? Do you have any Broadway mishaps? I am working on a Broadway project.
Of course you are. Are you being serious? Oh my gosh. Yes, I am. Starlight Express comes back. Not Starlight Express. Starlight Express. What is it?
Well, it will incorporate live skateboarding and music from Mark Mother's Ball, some of the diva library and that's a story of outcasts. Oh, all of a sudden Jason and Will are excited. Okay. Keep going. You know, that's, that's really cool. What a cool idea. How far along are you guys on that?
Yeah. And can John be part of it? Sorry. We, as far as we can get through COVID, but you know, we have, we have a, we have a book and we are working on music and everything. It's awesome. I mean, and Mark Mother's Ball is a genius. So it's been so fun listening or watching him come up with the stuff.
Hey, Tony, how many kids do you have? How old are they and do they skateboard? Between my wife and I, we have six kids. Whoa. Lord. Five boys, all adult age now, all in college or graduated college and they all skate. That's amazing. I have a 12 year old daughter that she dabbles in skating, but none of her friends really
do it. So she's not hooked on it the way they are. And do they feel any pressure to, to try to be as good as the greatest skateboarder of all time? I mean, how are they comfortable with that? Um, my oldest son, Riley, he's 28 actually, and he is a pro skater and is far better than I am in many ways. And the other ones, they don't, they don't take it as seriously.
They enjoy it very much and they're all very good in their own right, but they're not trying to make a career out of it. And they, I think they just enjoy the, the sort of auxiliary opportunities that we get, especially if we're traveling, one of the first stops always is whatever skate park is in the area. Right. Now, whenever I've seen you over the years, you always, you know, because of your line of work, you always get to dress however you want.
You're like right now and you're in a hoodie, you're skating, you're in shorts or whatever. It's always just super cash. Have you ever had a job where you actually had to wear like a suit or some kind of anything with buttons, any kind of uniform? Have you ever learned how to use a button? I don't know how to tie a tie. If that's what you're getting at, is that true? That is true.
Wow. Wow. I have one tie in my closet. It's pre-tied and I loosen it and then I tighten it. That is okay. And if anybody ever on ties that you're screwed, right? Oh, it's bad. Yeah.
It's bummer. I didn't really know how to tie a tie until I started doing the rest of development. And then I had to tie a tie every single morning for, what, a few years and- Is that true? That is true. Yeah. What about you, Sean? You any good with the tie?
Yeah. Look at me. Yeah. Of course you are. This is the first time Sean has been wearing a baseball hat in 19 years. I know. My hair is so good. To answer your question, the only real job I have was being a paper boy as a kid.
That's a bike and a front basket and long tosses. Yeah. I did it on a skateboard. Oh, did you really? I did it on a skateboard. It's hilarious. I did. Yeah.
Now, I'm sorry to digress for a second, but I'm a goofy foot. That means I'm a lefty Tracy. Same. Now, when I'm kicking, getting speed up, the kicking foot needs to go to the back of the board when you're done kicking, right? Not the front of the board. I think I'm doing it wrong and I think I'm teaching my daughter to do it wrong. Yeah.
So what you're describing is what we call Mongo and you are pushing with your front foot, correct? Yeah. You're so Mongo, dude. And Mongo is not rad. No. It's not rad, dude. It's not rad at all, dude.
You're so Mongo and so un-rad. So gross. Mongo's rongo. And if you want to get into the weeds, it's because you are pushing with your front foot and then when you put your front foot on the board, you have to readjust your back foot as well. Yeah. Yeah.
And there's a lot of adjusting happening. So a lot of things that can go wrong in that transition. Yes. And it's because you're insecure, right? It's because you're insecure and you have a lot of issues that you should deal with and you haven't dealt with because you're too Mongo in that. Mongo is a state of mind, right? Exactly.
Yes. I'm going to fucking kick your ass, aren't I? Mongo. Guys, I can't make it to, I can't do the podcast today. I'm feeling a little Mongo. I'm too Mongo. I'm too Mongo to do this. Oh my God.
Now, what do you have to say to the kids out there about elbow pads, knee pads, and helmet all the time or just when you're doing something that's carrying a lot of speed or you're dealing with the ramps, the half pipes, things like that? I mean, if you're just going down the street, you're getting from place A to place B, what kind of pads are we talking about? Any at all? Well, I recommend pads for beginners, absolutely. Helmet can save your life.
And especially when you're skating the bigger ramps and things, I mean, that's just pure survival. And now, a word from our sponsors. I want to talk about, Tony, the guys know I love to talk about this. What's the worst injury? I know you're probably sick of talking about it, but I'm fascinated with stuff like that. Worst injury and how long did it take to get over? I broke my pelvis and it took me about six weeks to walk with a severe limp.
How old were you? I think I was 37 or 38. How many times have you been to the emergency room? Over or under 15 times? Over. Oh, God. Oh, my God. Sean, you broke your pelvis when the Macarena came out, didn't you?
Because you just went so, you were so taken with the Macarena. I was so excited. And then what's the thing the kids do with the fists, shaking back and forth behind them and in front of them and behind them and in front of them? You resnapped it on that, I think, trying to learn that, right? Oh, that one. Yeah, yeah, yeah. What's that one called?
Oh, flossing, yeah. Flossing. Jason, did you just get an email from 2017, what happened? So Tony, so you went to the hospital, dozens of you broke your pelvis and I like the way you had to think about it. You're like, I guess when I broke my pelvis, did you ever have like a big injury when you were a kid and your folks were like, dude, you got to stop skateboarding? They never told me to stop, but they were concerned because I got a pretty bad concussion
early on, knocked out my front teeth, and I remember I had a string of injuries all in within a year when I started getting serious about skateboarding. And then they started sending me insurance forms in the mail as if I were an elderly, high risk patient. No way. So and my parents said, oh, this is because you've been to the hospital so many times. But I was lucky in that they knew I was going to keep doing it. What happened for you when the moment when you're like, oh, this, I'm going to march
right up in front of my parents and say, basically, how do you like me now? I told you it was going to work out and things are working out for me and start getting on board because look what just happened. Was it a check? Was it a contract? Was it an award? Honestly, I got really lucky. My parents were always supportive of it, even when the outlook was bleak.
And so they were as excited and surprised as I was when I was making money and I literally bought a house while I was a senior in high school. Wow. You bought a house while you were in high school. Yeah. In my senior year, my dad cosigned for it because I was not 18 yet because he was encouraging me to obviously put my money away because he could see that it kept coming and I was not really concerned with saving it.
That is officially rad. Yeah. And I know I've read things about you that you're an entrepreneur. You have a bunch of different businesses. What are they? Well, mostly my skate brand, Birdhouse skateboards. Yeah. We have one here at the house.
Oh, thank you. My 12-year-old has one. You're the reason we've been going for almost 30 years now. God, that's amazing. And then we have a foundation, the skate park project for public skate parks in their served areas. Hot clothing is a clothing brand that my siblings and I started for, well, it's basically supposed to be skate and surf clothing for kids.
That's so cool. But turned into something bigger than that. Do you have a lifelong battle with security guards? When you see a security guard, because they're the people who are trying to keep you from skating everywhere, do you see a security guard as your back arch up a little bit and you're like, here goes my enemy? I endured them through the years. Obviously.
I'm more of a skate park or ramp skater, so I'm more about skating in designated spots. But you would be surprised at the anomaly of the stuff that I can get away with sometimes when I get recognized. Of course. I'm sure. Yeah. You could just jump into somebody's backyard and start skating and then they came out and then they see it's Tony Hawk and then they're like, oh, yeah, it's cool.
No problem. Just keep at it. Do you need me to take the water out of this pool? Just give me a minute. Yeah, I'm sorry. Do you want something to drink? Can we film you? We went to an apartment complex where they had an empty swimming pool that we heard about
and we got there and they were very eager to kick us out. And then one of the guys recognized me and then they welcomed us and made barbecue for us. That's awesome. That's true. That is awesome. I want to know, how old were you and what was the moment where you kind of looked around and said, wait a minute, I can blow this thing out into a corporation much bigger than just
skating into all of these businesses that you started. Was there a person that caught your ear and was like, hey, if you were smart, you'd kind of like branch out and do all that stuff? Or was there something that inspired you that happened? You were like, wait a minute. I think now is the opportunity to hit while the iron is hot. I think it was in the early 2000s when suddenly my name was synonymous with video games and people started saying my name as more of a company or a brand than me personally.
That was when I realized that it had a broader reach and that I could probably have a lot more opportunity and maybe create other direction or other businesses through skateboarding. And that's when I started the boom of Huck Jam, which was an arena tour that featured skateboarding BMX and motocross. And it was all stemmed just from that sort of recognition factor that I had. That's really cool. Does your skateboarding talent translate similarly to a snowboarding talent or a surfing talent? A little.
I have been surfing almost as long as I've been skating, but I don't like big waves. I don't like being held underwater by the sheer force of them. And snowboarding is maybe a little bit closer for me. I've been doing that since, well, since actually it was invented. I wonder if, like, does Kelly Slater skate as well as you surf? Or does Sean White skate as well as you snowboard? I'd love to see that smackdown between the three of you guys. Yeah, that's a good idea.
I'll tell you, Sean White is an excellent skateboarder. He is a pro skateboarder as well as a pro snowboarder. Kelly on skateboard is not so much. Yeah. But he can play golf. My God. Yeah. Oh yeah.
He's a great dude. We should play with him. Wait, Tony, do you play golf? No. Okay. Well, we're going to start you real soon. The other thing is my son just finished my 12 year old, 12 and a half year old. He just did his first, he just did a week of surf camp and he did really great and he
had the same thing though. He was just like, there were a couple of days where there was a pretty big swell. Now I'm going to start using verbiage that Tony and I know because we're both kind of ran. Yeah. Kind of talk slow for me and Sean. Yeah. So there's a pretty sweet swell.
Anyway, he got, after the first week he got, they gave him the word for best wipeout because he took a board to the nose. Sorry. He was cleaning something? You said wipeout? No, no. He took a board to the nose. He was not awake.
I know. Jason's such an inside cat. He was cleaning something, something fell on him so he swelled and we were, we were out. They were kind of barreling. Well, okay. So here's the deal. So we're, anyway, the point is he's surfing and he took the thing to the nose and I understand that thing about surfing, I didn't surf my first time until my thirties and sometimes
when those waves get big, I'm like, yeah, I'm scared of being held down by a huge wave. That kind of bums me out. I like a lot of the other stuff, but that thing really freaks me out and also the water tastes like shit. Yeah. There's that. But, you know, maybe we can put a little, we can put a little stevia in it to cut the salt.
Have you guys, Jason and Sean, have you guys ever served a little stevia? Yeah, man. No. Are you kidding me? When? When? When? When?
I mean, I'm bored of it now. A lot. No, I do. I know you skateboarded. I once stood up on a board just long enough, and it's just been the one time, but long enough to go, oh, wait a second. The waves get smaller once you stand up. I did a lot of boogie boarding when I was a kid and of course the waves are at their
max height because you're always on your belly. But once you stand up on something, you're like, oh, I'm already six feet. So a six foot wave is, you know, I'm looking at right in the eye, so it's fine now. But that just happened the once. I'm remembering, Jason, you talking about, and correct me if I'm wrong, but hearing Tony talking about skating as a kid is reminding you of you with your skateboard on the bus in Woodland Hills. Is that ringing a bell?
Yeah. I did, I did skate quite a bit when I was a kid living in the valley and when I had to get myself to auditions, I would jump on the, on the bus and ride it into downtown and then I'd have to skate a bunch of blocks to my audition. So I'd have my little skateboard and my headshot, my resume and a Manila envelope just skating down in Hollywood Boulevard at 12 years old and, you know, just trying to make a living man while you were, you know, figuring out how to flick boogers in elementary school punk. So you're OG.
Jason, you are OG. Oh, he's OG. Yeah, man. Back when it was, they were plastic boards with big, dumb, ugly wheels, you know, and only one tail on that thing. I don't believe you're on a plastic board. I don't believe you're that way. Yeah.
Yeah. It bent in the middle. It was, but well before wood was invented. Those skinny ones. Those real skinny ones. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sean, have you ever skated? Did you ever skate at all? I did. I had a skateboard when I was little, but, you know, I tried it once or twice and wiped out and I was like, well, that doesn't feel good. So why do it? Yeah. Why put yourself through it?
Why put myself in that position to just wipe out again and hurt myself. I didn't understand. And then back in the red wagon. Right. Yeah. And then back. Screw this skateboard. And I've had Tracy pull me all around the neighborhood.
Tony, what's your, what's your least favorite thing, a sort of thing that's out there about skating, like some sort of cliche or something that that's always bummed you out or just feels really inorganic. You're like, ah, that's not, um, well, I think that there, there were a lot of stereotypes about skating or skaters that they were just stoners or outcasts or problematic. And I think that it was just more that they were looking for something else. You know, they, they were not, they didn't fit into team sports with like, that's how I discovered it.
I didn't really feel like I fit into team sports and, and I found this, this tribe of misfits that were very artistic, very creative. Um, and the whole idea that skaters are, are just trying to be, uh, punks is more because they didn't have any place to skate. So they skated on public property and hence the whole security guard issue and, um, and I feel like when you look deeper into it, you see that skaters are disciplined. They're creative. They're responsible.
I mean, most of my friends are dads and they skate when they can and, you know, they pay mortgage and just have regular lives. Given that skating is so sort of simplistic, the physics of it, just a board and some wheels under it, um, it could have started like literally back when the wheel was invented. Um, do we, is there an agreed upon start of skateboarding? Like who invented the skateboard? Do we know? We already make fly in 1957, right?
I'll tell you what, that was, that movie was a huge boost for skating in the eighties. For sure. Yeah, I'm sure. Massive. I'm sure. Yeah. Um, no, it's, it's, it's always hotly debated of how it started. Um, the, the general consensus is that someone took a two by four and nailed roller skate
trucks and wheels to it. What year that was or where that was is undetermined. Wow. That would be, uh, I smell a movie in that you mentioned, you mentioned like a bunch of your friends that are dads that still skate at what point and what age do you look at them and go, oh, maybe it's time to cop on that thing. Yeah. What is the cut off there?
Is it, is it osteoporosis when, you know, if you just catch a small rock and you jump off the board, everything snaps, that's probably the age, right? And what is that 70? I'll let you know when I get there. Yeah. That's great. I think I'm the one testing the water is the most. Yeah, I mean, you don't see that when you see those big pharmaceutical ads for like,
you know, heart thinning stuff and whatever, you never see them skateboarding, right? Like they're on walks and stuff, I guess when you're, yeah, exactly. Um, Tony, is there another sport that you look up to that either you've always wanted to try and you're like, gosh, you know, that is just, that is the ultimate, you know, you have the ultimate respect for that. And is there one specific one? Um, I do have a huge respect for the people who ride giant waves. I mean, that just seems so terrifying in terms of survival.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Laird Hamilton's got, uh, got nerds for all of us probably. Okay. Yeah. I mean, it's just, you know, when you, when you see, but also I feel like the technology has come a long ways.
So obviously they have, they're better equipped for emergencies, but it just to go out there and to know that like, I'll skate a ramp any day, any size ramp, but I know that that ramp is not going to crash down on top of me once I fall. Right. Right. Right. Right. Yeah.
Like Laird Hamilton, he's kind of, he's kind of an outlier too. Like you, like he kind of did his own, like he's created his own thing in big wave surfing. Right. Yeah. And he, he kind of pioneered a lot of that. Am I wrong about that? Or am I right about that? No, absolutely.
He, and he lives in a different realm of safety than anyone else I've ever met. So cool. Tony, what kind of, what kind of music do you listen to? Or do you have like favorite bands or a certain type of music that you would listen to? Oh, and then tell us your favorite color and your fucking astrological sign. Hey, man. Why don't you fucking dig a little bit deep? This is your guest for Christ's sake.
I'm trying to put him in a box. I want to see if he's like into like, want to know if he's into like Southern California, kind of like that sort of pop punk bands, like the Blink 182's, if that's his deal or if he's more old school indie like me. Skater related. Yeah. Cause we're the same age. We're roughly the same age.
Yeah. I would say more older punk, you know, like The Clash, Circle Jerks, Black Flag, that kind of stuff because. Sex pistols. Sex pistols. Yeah. I mean, that, that, that was the soundcheck to the skate parks when I grew up. And that's what I knew and loved and Devo is heavily on rotation.
Yeah. Mark them out of the spot. There we go. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. What is the thing like Tony Hawk, Tony Hawk skating and the video games and everything about your life is, is out there in the world of sporting. What is the thing that people are like, I didn't know.
Like the, the Broadway musical, people are like, wait, you're working on a Broadway musical. That's pretty cool. Is there anything else like that that people would be like, wait a minute, what? I used to play violin when I was a kid. Oh, that's amazing. I literally gave it up for skating. Wow. Because my music teacher told me that I had to choose one or the other.
Wow. And, and do you miss it? I do miss it. Yes. And at the time it was really kind of a toss up what had the best income potential between the two careers. Right. I mean, I don't think either one, either one was, was, uh, we're choosing glory.
Uh-huh. Were you mad at your violin teacher for making you give up the violin a little bit? Is there a little, I sent some resentment. A little bit. Yeah. I feel like I should have just kept playing for fun, but I listened to him and you know what you could do. And this is a good way to maybe it might be cathartic and good way to kind of get over
that is find out where they are, your violin teacher, go and buy their house and then as soon as it closes, tear down the house and berate them and say, this is your, this is on you. You made me do this. You know, if you picked it up again, could you play right away or no, I tried. It was, no, it was not easy. And do you like classical music? Do you listen to that stuff?
Not really. But I, I think that if I were to pick it up again, I would try to just cover old songs like clash and sex pistols. Yeah. No, if you, but if you, if you rolled up to a, to a stoplight and you're on your skateboard and you're pretty cool and you're very rad and all of a sudden you pulled up and there's some dude in a family car and he's playing classical music by himself, would you be like, what a nerd.
And I'm talking about Jason. Wait man. Not at all. No. My wife is a huge fan of classical. And so sometimes when I get in her car, that's what's blasting. Hey, have you had any, any embarrassing design sessions with any of these? These video game animators about hammering them that, no dude, I don't skate like that
or my face doesn't look like that. Or do you really grind them on, on sort of on your style? Do you care about the accuracy of your likeness and any of these, you know, are you, are you a stickler about a certain, a certain part of your technique that, that you like them to get right? I think that that's probably my biggest job through doing video games now is, is keeping it authentic because they've already figured out how skateboarding works, motion graphics locations and things.
So really, I just need to, I just need to step in there and say, no, this grind should look like this. You should be catching the board like this on this trick and yeah, I get into the weeds on it. Do you ever wear any of those motion capture suits and, and he's probably done it a million times, right? Yeah. Many times.
Oh wow. That's so cool. So much in the time since the first Tony Hawk game in the over, over 20 years that you quite literally probably know a lot about motion capture and the evolution of it, right? Yeah. I did it early on where you had to wear all the ping pong balls and, and have a million cameras set up that took forever. And I do remember getting in the suit that is, is so, it's, it's already embarrassing.
You're feeling very vulnerable and the skin tight suit with all these balls and then, and it was like, okay, go do your hardest tricks and go. Jason, you never had to turn tricks with balls, right? No, not only, not a bunch of balls all over me, but cameras, cameras were always on and there was, there was a maximum of two balls, but so Tony, are you the best at those games? Like, I imagine there's some competitions that, how would you place in those, the video game competitions? I can hold my own, I've learned through the years that if you have a game with your name
on it, you should be able to play it and at least know how to complete it without cheating. But there are people that have a lot more time to spend on it and they get scores that are 10 times what I can do, 100 times what I can do sometimes. I've played it many times. I've owned a few versions of your games, just FYI, I didn't want to lead with that, but I'm a bit of a gamer and it's an excellent game, excellent game. Well, we remastered, if I may, we remastered the first two and so they're out on all the new systems, including Switch was just released yesterday.
Wow, all right. Brad. Nice. I'm on it. Sean, I guess we just figured out what you're doing tonight. Yeah. Yeah, for my birthday. I'm just going to go.
Oh yeah. Happy birthday, Sean. Happy birthday. Yeah. Thanks so much. Thanks. My brother texted me a picture of my mom's glass eye and said, mom and I wish you a happy birthday.
His mom's been dead for a few years, Tony, just so in case you didn't know. Just FYI. Well, Sean, listen, Sean, happy birthday. Your dad and I are, I'm having drinks with your dad tonight, his father's day, and he reached out to me to hang, but um. That's cool. That makes sense. Oh, wait, Tony.
Sorry. Sorry, Tony. We digress. Yes, your video game. I'm going to get it. I'm going to buy it. I'm going to win it. And then I'll text it to you.
I appreciate it. I'm getting it for you for your birthday. Thank you. Yeah. So, so Tony, and so you have this, this foundation where you create all this, you know, space for kids to use, blah, blah, blah, like, you know, by the way, I say blah, blah, blah, like a complete jerk. But yeah, what I mean is this is something that's.
That's our mission statement. Actually, blah, blah, blah, skate parks, blah, blah, blah, I just mean that it's a lot. Yeah. You guys do a lot of stuff. I know, Angel. Yeah. I know.
How long, what do you, do you see a sort of a breakthrough? Has there been a tipping point in terms of, okay. Just sounded out. Are you bored? Are you bored by what Tony's doing? I mean, Jesus Christ, Jason. No, plan the plane, bro. Check your notes.
I'm asking what is the goal? Is it, is it everybody skateboarding by 2050? Like that's, that's what I mean, like, are we all in a skateboard nation? No, the goal is more to have public skate parks in underserved areas, but also just so that anyone can go find a skate park in their area. We've been doing it 20 years and we've helped to fund over 500 parks that are completed now and we're coming into 900 that have been funded. And that's the work I'm most proud of.
I think if I had, if I had to choose a legacy of some sort, that would be it. That nut job Elon Musk said, Hey, why don't you hop on my jet and we'll go to the skateboard on the moon. Would you do it? Yeah, sure. Sure, I would. Wow. Yeah, who wouldn't?
I would love to see. As long as it doesn't cost me anything. Yeah. By the way, I said, I said Elon Musk is a nut job. I don't mean, I mean that job in a great way. This guy's done incredible things. No, we all took it that way. Now, skate parks seem like a real easy thing to put into a city budget, right?
I mean, it's just basically, we need a bit of land, dig a hole and then shape it, pour some cement. I mean, it's about the cheapest thing you can do with civic engineering, I would imagine, right? Yeah, you would think it would be that easy. It's more the stigma in skateboarding and they think that the skate parks are somehow going to attract a bad crowd and be a bad influence. And that's usually the biggest barrier for getting skate parks approved.
Because we approve projects or give them funding. That's usually the endorsement they need to get it sort of pushed through all the red tape. You know, it's funny, like you spend all your time, you talked about the stereotypes of like, you know, it's a bunch of stoners and whatever. But now given the environment we live in, can you imagine if you finally, if you announced that you were releasing a line of weed, all your critics would be like, see, see, he's just been waiting.
We knew it. We knew it. We knew it all along. So we're like, this is really good for Ollie's. This type of weed is really good for doing trick, you know what I mean? This is like skate park weed. This is just like parking lot weed. After the skate park, wind down weed.
They all just have trick names. I'll bet you'd have a real decision to make if somebody approached you with just licensing just a weed brand. You can hand over fist now that it's all legal. You're 53. Come on, man. We're not going to judge you, dude. We're totally, I will defend you.
I will defend you. Just gummies, you know, not, not, not any flower, bro. Oh, does somebody like gummies around here? No, I hear that they're fantastic though. Skateboard shaped gummies. Yes. Oh, there we go. See, this guy's got so many good ideas.
It's unbelievable. There you go. That's it. Where do you stand on the, on the, on the skateboards with the motors on them? Does it make you cringe? No, no, I don't, it's, it's fine with me. That's the one I'll take. People say, you know, they're, they're all these, these purists that say, well, longboards
is not skateboarding because they're just transportation. And I say, hey, whatever gets you out there and on a skateboard and active is fine with me. Amen. Yeah. Yeah. A lot of people out there with complaints these days with stuff like that, you know, and everybody's taking positions and you know what my position is?
Shut up. Yeah. Well, Tony, we've taken up way too much of your time, especially considering it's your anniversary weekend. Yeah. What an absolute honor to have you on the show. It's so nice. Honestly.
You're incredible. Very nice of you to spend some time with us. Hey, I appreciate you guys having me on. It's a, I'm a huge fan. I listen to your show and all your other work as well. Thanks, man. We're going to listen to yours. Thank you.
Good luck with your, with your podcast that's out now and, and maybe I'll see you over there at this week. Yeah. Let's go. We'll be here. All right. All right, pal. Thanks, Tony.
See you guys. Bye, Tony. Bye. Bye, Tony. Thank you. Tony is a super nice fella. Yeah, he's really nice. He always, he always seems nice in the interviews that I've seen him on.
I'm so glad that I wasn't wrong with that. Yeah. He's great. He's always looked 15. And then when he said he had a 28 year old kid, how old the fella is, is Tony Hawk? I think he's 53. And he's still skating. That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah. He's still skating. He looks terrific. Doesn't he? Doesn't he look incredible? Well, by the way, one of the, the, for me, the funniest, one of the funniest lines from today's show. Oh, we're going to do highlights?
Yeah. It was when Jason said, oh, I wasn't sitting. Hey, well, I wasn't sitting in class learning how to flick booger. By the way, and you know what I resent about that? I was sitting in class. I was teaching how to flick boogers. All right. I apologize.
I apologize. Sean, I'm just, I moved out of the house at age 12, by the way. That's a true story. Moved or dismissed. I was moved out of the house and sent to all boys boarding school age 12. Sean, I cannot believe you're sharing some of your birthday with us. Why, why don't you just say, listen, Saturday doesn't work for me because it sounds like Sean, you and the Hawks need to coordinate next year and start doing your birth, your
birthday and their anniversary together, like you and Scotty and the Hawks in New York. Yeah. Right. Just catching shows. How cool is it? How cool is it? Tony Hawk is his real name. I know.
That's one of the most people have to change their name to sound. I'm very excited about his, his skateboard Broadway show sounds very cool. I love that. When you said, what did you say? Starlight Express is coming back. Starlight Express. I hate to age myself here, but that was like a real eye opener, right? When they all those.
Yeah. Everybody was on skates. Roller skates. Yeah. The stage that they built for that. It was just a bunch of half pipes and tubes. I never saw it. I don't think it was a big hit, but I never saw it.
Was it not? It was one of the biggest flops of all time. Is that true? Yeah. It was a huge flop. Yeah. Because they spent so much money on all the stuff you just described. Sean, how excited will you be to go and see the Tony Hawk?
Yeah. Who would it be? I'd see that. By the way, that's what's cool is like seeing, seeing skateboarding live on stage every night. Like I can only imagine the set they're building must be massive. You see, now I could like Broadway. Now I could like a Broadway show if there's always the chance that they could crash and shut up.
You know what I mean? The Cirque du Soleil, do you ever go in there and wait for some tragedy? Well, that's not Broadway. Well, you know, but it sounds like you like to sit there and wait for something terrible to happen. I do like some Broadway. It should be noted. I say that in jest.
There have been many shows that I've gone to that were great. Cats. You've been to a half dozen times, haven't you? I've never seen cats. Really? I never saw cats. Never. Lem is never.
But you know, if you really want to go see that Tony Hawk show, you should be first in line to buy a ticket, buy a ticket, happy birthday, Shawnee, happy birthday, Shawnee. The next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early and on Amazon Music or by subscribing to Wondery Plus and the Wondery app. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob vistErf SmartList. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.